hey guys it's Jonah here I love bakdae I
love to train my back and I love how
strong lean and toned
they look so I'm gonna share with you my
favorite back exercises when I do
strength training in the gym let's start
lifting we're going to work on the
entire back muscles your lats mid back
upper back and also lower back start by
performing each of the exercises for 15
to 20 repetitions and aim for 2 to 3
sets with a 30 to 60 seconds rest in
between
I love the cable machines so let's start
with that first workout will be lat
pulldown this machine works on your lats
or I like to call it your wings hold a
bat in a white grip chest upwards back
slightly arched and feet firmly on the
ground
as you exhale pull the bat down towards
your chest squeeze the shoulder blades
together for one count and feel the
contraction on your lats inhale and
slowly release the bar back to starting
position arms fully extended and your
lats are fully stretched and repeats
avoid swinging your body back and forth
the upper torso should remain stationary
and the movement should only come from
your forearms next workout a seated
cable row this workout focuses more on
the mid back muscles sit and place your
feet firmly on the front platform
keeping your knees soft and slightly
bent hold the handles firmly and keep
your upper body in a neutral position
and your elbows slightly bent as you
exhale pull the handles towards your
torso and focus on squeezing your
shoulder blades together your back
should be slightly arched and your chest
should be sticking out keep your elbows
pointed back and close to your body do
not spread the elbows out to the sides
squeeze your mid-back muscles and hold
the contraction for one count and slowly
release back to the starting position
and repeat
again avoid moving your entire body the
movement should be coming from your arms
straight arm pull downs this is another
really effective workout to hit the lats
grab the bar with a palms facing down
and step up backwards about two feet
keeping your chest up and open bend your
torso forward at the waist by about
thirty degrees
with your arms fully extended in front
of you with a slight bend at the elbows
while still keeping the arm straight
through the bar done by contracting the
leg muscles until your hands are close
to your thighs still keeping your arms
straight slowly release to the starting
position and repeat you should feel the
burn on your lats and also your core to
keep you balanced now let's move over
and work with the dumbbells and as a
barbells let's start with deadlift this
is an extremely important workout to add
into your routine to build strength and
stability for the entire body for this
workout you can go heavier I'd say
between fifteen to thirty kilos start
standing with your feet shoulder width
apart and knees slightly bent grab the
bar with the palms facing down about
shoulder width apart keep your upper
body in a neutral position back flat and
chest opened then slowly lower the
barbell as far as you can towards the
floor by bending at your hip joint not
your waist the bar should always remain
close to your thighs hold the post at
the bottom for a second and squeeze your
gluts and your lower back to pull
yourself back up to the starting
position you should feel your muscles
working on your hamstrings glutes core
lower back and also your shoulders
basically your entire body working
together as a unit the next workout is
bent over barbell row this targets
primarily your mid-back so go slightly
lighter between 10 to 20 kilos similar
to the exercise before us then with the
feet shoulder-width apart and knees
slightly bent hold the bar with palms
facing down keep your upper body in a
neutral position back flat and chest
opens then forward until your torso is
roughly parallel to the floor pull the
barbell to your waist keeping the elbows
close to your body and pointed back do
not spread your elbows out to the sides
squeeze the mid-back muscles for one
count and slowly return to starting
position
avoid hunting or using momentum to lift
the weights again the movement should
only be coming from your forearms single
arm dumbbell row
to avoid a muscle imbalance it is a good
idea to focus and work on one side at a
time
this workout also focuses on the
mid-back we want to use a bench for this
so let's start with the right side band
other hips and place your left leg and
left palm on the bench to support
yourself plant your right foot firmly on
the floor beside the bench
hold one dumbbell in your right hand
letting it hang straight down this is
your starting position pull the
dumbbells straight up to the side of
your chest keep your unclose to your
site elbow pointed back and your torso
stationary squeeze your shoulder blades
together and feel the burn on your right
mid-back lower the dumbbells down in a
slow and controlled manner and repeat
once you've completed all the reps then
switch sides
I like to end my back workout by working
on smaller muscles so reverse fly works
on the upper back and also showed us
because it is a smaller muscle group go
for lighter weights between two to three
kilos each band forward at your hips
until your torso is nearly parallel to
the floor hold the dumbbells firmly at
about shoulder level pumps facing each
other and elbows slightly bent then
raise your arms straight out to your
sides
in line with your body squeeze your
upper back and shoulders for two counts
slowly lower arms back to starting
position
always keep your back flat and chest
open your upper body should remain as
still as possible with movements only
coming from your arms and remember avoid
rounding your back or collapsing your
chest and avoid using momentum or
swinging your entire body to lift at the
waist so these are my favourite back
exercise
when I hit at the gym what are your
favorite bag exercises let me know in
the comments below you might find
yourself as struggling to begin with but
that's okay keep track of your workout
and slowly progress by increasing the
weight reducing the rest time or
increasing each exercise to four sets
challenge yourself and always give it
your best shot do these exercises at
least twice weekly and don't forget to
also work on your total body remember
that proper form is extremely important
to always check that you're performing
the exercise in the correct manner don't
forget to hit the subscribe button for a
lot more worker videos fitness tips and
other recipes on my channel are the best